[MUSIC PLAYING]
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Now, I just
want to tell you how
the Art Foundation
and Google work together.
So we are the biggest partner
of Google in the Middle East
when it comes to art.
We have over 900 works online.
It is the biggest
library of Arab art
in the world online is what we
have hosted on the Google Art
Project.
About 40 or 50 of the works are
in this ultra-high resolution
gigapixel camera.
They took over my house,
the Google camera.
Not only do we
have-- is there a--
oh, there is this.
So not only do we
have the artworks
that you can zoom
in forever and ever,
but we also have exhibitions.
So if someone says, Sultan, what
did you show in Tehran in 2016?
I don't know what were the works
that were in your exhibition,
I tell them, go
on Google, and you
will see the exhibition,
the works that were shown.
And this is something that
hasn't been released yet,
but we're working with Google
on exclusively Google-curated
exhibitions.
So this is something
that Google is launching
all over the world, and we
are their first partner here
in the Middle East.
So these are exhibitions--
I don't know that
thing is doing.
Maria, this is your computer.
You need to stop it.
MARIA: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Oh, OK.
You need it back?
Fine.
So this is exclusive
for Google online.
We also partnered with Google
on the Street View project
for one of our exhibitions.
And we've partnered
with Google Chrome.
So believe it or not--
maybe I shouldn't
be telling you this,
but Google asked
for 20 images so
that they would upload them
into their Chrome international
library.
So when people use
the Chrome extension,
a Japanese painting will appear,
a Brazilian artist will appear,
an American painting
will appear.
But we sort of took things
overboard, and we uploaded 900.
[LAUGHTER]
So it is very strange.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm not sure I should
be telling you this.
But it is-- for the propensity
of the number of times
that our works show
up is shocking even
to me, the fact of how many
works show up on and on and on.
So for example, that was
Nouri Al Rawi from Iraq.
This is Noor Al
Suwaidi from the UAE.
And we also-- Google had
the pop-up exhibition.
They took over a house
two or three years ago.
I'm not sure if you
guys were aware of it.
And so we loaned them art.
I just wanted to show you--
oh, and on Instagram also, we
have the only Middle
Eastern artworks
that appear on the Google
Instagram account, which
is very, very popular.
Now, this is the presentation.
From now, I hope to take
about 30 minutes of your time.
We will talk about the political
undertones of iconic works
of the Middle East.
Now, Middle Eastern
artists and Arab artists
have been documenting major
events for over a century.
So ever since you had the
introduction of schools--
academies and schools into
the Middle East, the first one
having been founded
in 1908 in Egypt--
there was a young
prince from Egypt.
He was the nephew of the king,
and he wanted to study art.
And he couldn't leave.
So they opened an academy
for him, which is amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
His name is Youssef Kamal.
And he said, you know, uncle,
King whoever your name was,
I want an academy.
They opened an academy for him.
And that was the first academy,
first opened in Alexandria
and then moved down to Cairo.
And since then you've
had systemic education
when it came to art.
But you also had
a lot of artists,
especially if you come
from Christian backgrounds
in the Middle East, who
studied in the church.
They studied painting, whether
it was people like Nicola Saig,
whether it was people--
artists like [INAUDIBLE],,
artists like Gibran Kahlil
Gibran, and others
who were maybe
not going to the church
for religious reasons.
But because the
church was present,
they were able to learn from a
lot of the artists and artisans
and craftsmen who were there.
This is a very
important painting
that's part of the Shoman
Foundation collection in Amman,
and it shows you the
surrender of Jerusalem
to the British in 1980.
Now, Nicola Saig was not there.
He took the photograph.
And he said, I need
to document it myself.
And so he repainted the work.
And this is one of
the first works where
you see artists
painting iconic events,
capturing iconic events
not just with camera
but with their brushstrokes.
Now, who of you have heard of
the Degenerate Art Exhibition
of the 1930s in Germany?
Has anyone here heard of it?
Who hasn't heard of it?
Let me see if you guys
are paying attention.
OK, I'm guessing-- there's a
few of you who have heard of it
and haven't heard of it,
which is very interesting.
But I won't ask.
So what happened was that the
horrible, horrible government
of the 1930s and '40s
Germany, the Nazi regime,
collected a lot of
art that they consider
to be un-German, unworthy
of being called German.
And some of the artists
were Emil Nolde.
They had Paul Klee,
some of the leading
lights of European culture.
But these were modernists,
and they were not
painting iconic-- they were
not painting what you would see
traditionally as European art.
And so what the
German government did
was that they were trying
to dehumanize them.
Many of them were
Jews, but a lot of them
were not Jews as well.
So as part of the effort
to dehumanize them,
they collected all
their artworks,
and they hung them in a--
not a museum, but
almost like a warehouse.
And these works were
hung all over each other.
They were badly lit.
There was no attempt
to give these works
any kind of respect.
And at the same time, they
opened another exhibition
across the street in
a beautiful building,
and the works were
very well lit.
And the artworks
had space for them
so that you can go
and admire them.
There were tour guides.
And so they wanted to
show you the contrast
of what is un-German,
what is degenerate art,
and what is German art.
This exhibition, people
were forced to attend it.
Students from schools
had to go and attend this
so that they can see how
these works are unworthy
of being German.
You can see--
I mean, some of them
really are-- look at that.
Dada is a very important
movement that took place
in the 1920s, for example.
So what happened was a lot of
intellectuals around the world
were horrified by this.
Because again, this
is mass dehumanization
of people, which followed
the persecution of a lot
of the minorities in Europe.
So this is a photo
I found today.
I'm so proud of it.
This is a photograph of Andre
Breton, the French philosopher;
the Russian dissident,
Leon Trotsky;
and the Mexican
artist, Diego Rivera.
Now, they came together in
Mexico in 1938, a few months
after this exhibition.
And they issued a
manifesto, the manifesto
for an independent
revolutionary art.
And they said in this
manifesto that we are disgusted
by what happened in Germany.
You're not supposed to treat
intellectuals and prosecute
them like this.
And so as you noticed,
a Russian, a Mexican,
a European-- so there's
an international outcry
as a result.
But what was interesting
and what people don't know
is that there was equally--
there was an equal outcry
here in the Middle East.
A bunch of intellectuals from
the Middle East, from Egypt,
gathered in Cairo and
issued their own manifesto.
So this is where
we come in, and we
have to highlight our
own history as well.
We were also part of this
international movement
to condemn the
persecution of Jews
and of intellectuals and
artists under the Nazi regime.
So as you see, this is
a photograph from 1941.
But their first
meeting was 1938,
so just a few months after
the Degenerate Art exhibition.
You can see some of their names.
They came from
different backgrounds.
Many of them were Muslim,
Christian, Jewish.
Many of them were
ethnic Egyptian.
And many of them were immigrants
to Egypt, who became Egyptian,
but they were immigrants.
They had Italian background,
Greek background,
and other backgrounds.
So they came together
and they formed
a group called the
Art and Liberty Group.
They issued a magazine called
"The Evolution Magazine."
It came out, I think,
every other month.
They met for a period of
almost eight, nine years.
And they did five
major exhibitions.
This is their manifesto.
So just like the
Mexican and the Russian
and the other intellectuals
issued the manifesto,
there was a manifesto that
came out of Cairo in 1939--
'38, sorry-- December 1938.
And look what
they're saying here.
They're saying that--
basically what they're saying
is what is happening in Europe
is something that is revolting.
We see this as the
new Middle Ages
rising in the heart of Europe.
So they're condemning
what's happening in Europe.
So this is really sort
of a stand of solidarity
with the European intellectuals
and the Jews of Europe
and the artists of Europe
signed by all these luminaries.
I just want to show you the
names of the men and women.
And you can tell
from their names
what their backgrounds were.
I just want to give
you a couple of seconds
to look over the names.
This is the kind of
art that they produced.
It was very similar to
the so-called Degenerate
Art of Europe.
It is nothing-- when you
think of Egyptian art
of the early 20th century,
you would think of landscapes.
You would think of pyramids.
You think of people standing
in the market, Khan el-Khalili,
and these beautiful places
that we know in Egypt.
However, this is what
they have been producing.
They've been producing
work that is modern,
that is cutting
edge, that really
is talking about the new
identity of the 1930s
and the 1940s in
Egypt and elsewhere.
This is a great artist, for
example, who was the youngest
member of the group.
She wasn't officially a member,
but she exhibited with them.
Her name was Inji Efflatoun.
We'll come back to
her a number of times.
She is one of the most important
and influential artists
of the Middle East
of the 20th century.
And this is-- can
you see the work?
It looks like trees that
are women that are nude.
Her work is really incredible.
And I give lectures
about Inji Efflatoun.
So we can come
back to her later.
So again, remember how Nicola
Saig did not attend an event
but then decided
to go and paint it
because he thought
it was so important,
the surrender of Jerusalem
to the British in 1918?
Inji Efflatoun did
the same thing.
And she went and she
painted this massacre,
the Dinshaway Massacre of Egypt
of the early 20th century.
I don't suspect many
of you have heard--
any Egyptians here have heard
of the Dinshaway Massacre?
Have you heard of it?
Who has heard of the
Dinsha-- you've heard of it?
So not even all Egyptians know.
But it was a milestone event
in the history of Egypt.
What happened, basically, was a
bunch of British soldiers, who
were basically the
occupying force of Egypt,
went hunting in this
town in the Nile Delta.
And they shot pigeons.
However, in Egypt, the
pigeons are not just--
they are kept, because they
are the source of livelihood.
People raise the pigeons.
They sell the pigeons.
Their income comes from
the keeping of the pigeons.
So they went for sport, and they
started shooting the pigeons.
And so people went and
protested very briefly.
And they pushed the
British soldiers away,
but the Egyptian soldiers--
the British soldiers
were wearing these
very heavy overalls.
And so one of them later
collapsed and died,
and they accused the Egyptian
peasants, the farmers
and the peasants of
having killed him.
And they had an Egyptian
judge basically pass
a sentence of hanging
against two or three
of the Egyptian peasants.
And so Inji Efflatoun captures
this very important event.
What happened after
that was that it
was covered in the media and
was seen as an example and even
led to the multiple Egyptian
uprisings against the British.
And now we are being--
we are being pushed.
They are even taking away
our source of livelihood.
So this really led to
the uprisings of 1919.
It was a small event, but
it was the buildup of it.
So here you see the
British soldiers sort
of standing watch, looking at
this guy who is being executed
or being hanged while his family
is crying, asking for mercy.
Again, Inji Efflatoun
was not present.
She was born in the 1920s.
However, she thought this was
such an important event that
took place 40-odd years ago
that I have to capture it.
Not all artists had
a bad relationship
with the government.
This is an Egyptian artist, for
example, George Hanna Sabbagh,
who was one of the first
artists to go and to exhibit
in the Salon d'Automne in Paris
in the early 20th century.
But George was very
close to the king,
and he was gifting the
king a lot of gifts.
So a lot of artists benefited
from a good relationship.
Just like they do here in the
UAE and the Gulf and elsewhere,
they benefit a lot from
having a good relationship
with the monarch and
the ruling family.
Actually, this reads "Gift
to [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]."."
So it was a gift to
the Egyptian monarch.
This is one of my favorite
paintings in the world.
There's two copies of it.
I'll tell you the reason why.
One of them is owned, thank
God, by the Egyptian estate.
And the other one is
owned by [INAUDIBLE]..
This artist was approached
by his boss, Yousuf--
or by his teacher, Yousuf Amin.
So Abdel Hady El Gazzar
was the son of a cleric.
And he was studying
art under Yousuf Amin.
And Yousuf Amin told
him, by the way,
there's going to
be an exhibition.
And some of the works are
going to be gifted to the king.
Would you like to
paint something
that we can give to the king?
And it's very prestigious.
Your work will be in
the royal collection.
A lot of people will see it.
You will have a future
if you paint something.
He said, sure, why not.
I'll paint something.
He painted this work
and was thrown in jail.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, I want to give you guys
a few seconds to tell me,
why do you think he was
thrown in jail more than once?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Maybe because
of "The Naked Lady?"
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
"The Naked Lady?"
Who thinks it's because
of "The Naked Lady?"
OK, now, because I
asked it that way.
Who has another explanation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Huh?
"The Plate," "The Empty Plate."
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: It's
demonstrative of the poverty
of Egyptians at that time.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
I knew Google hires
the best minds and abilities.
So yes, actually,
you're very right.
This painting was
seen as an affront
to the Egyptian monarch.
The message basically is in
your kingdom, your majesty,
everyone is poor and
suffering and hungry.
And so he was picked up,
along with his poor teacher--
Yousuf Amin had
nothing to do with it.
He was picked up, both were
picked up, thrown in jail.
And finally, Mahmoud
Sa'id, who was
a very important
Egyptian artist, who
was the uncle of
the queen, went,
and he basically was able to
ask for clemency and mercy.
And they were able
to release them.
But the guy was really
unhappy, the artist.
I'll show you what he did later.
So the artist, as you can tell--
Abdel Hady El Gazzar was--
when the Egyptian
revolution took place,
do you think he was
sorry to see the king go?
AUDIENCE: No.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Not so much.
He goes, well,
this guy jailed me.
I'm not really sad that
he is no longer there.
So in fact he was very close to
the government of Abdel Nasser.
And in 1962, Egypt
introduced a new constitution
that Abdel Nasser
had commissioned.
And this is a painting
that he created,
which is also, thankfully,
owned by the Egyptian state,
to celebrate the
new constitution.
There's a lot of messages here.
But can you see what's happening
over there in the back?
I like this a lot.
There's a Muslim imam and a
priest hugging each other.
They're so happy.
I don't know why they're
happy, but they're happy.
And then here you see
the farmer and the worker
holding the wheat
and the flower.
Is this wheat and flour?
AUDIENCE: Cotton.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Cotton?
Is it cotton in their hand,
almost kneeling in prayer.
You know, it is such an
iconic piece of Egypt,
and it's called
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] in Arabic,
"The Charter."
And it was exhibited
in Korea last month,
which I'm very happy about.
What led to, basically, this
new identity that took place
across the Middle East?
What happened was a lot of the--
across the Middle East, what
the region shared in common was
they were all under
foreign occupation,
either as protectorates or
as a proper colonial rule.
They were all under governments
that didn't give them
a lot of freedoms, whether they
were pre or post-colonial rule.
And so one of the
only places that they
were able to gather the artists
were these fine art societies.
And not only were the
artists gathering,
but they also invited
intellectuals.
So you have poets, you have
singers, you have journalists,
you have professors and lawyers.
They all gathered in
these fine arts societies,
and they were able
to exchange ideas.
And in this exchange of
ideas, a new identity emerged.
When you look at the first
half of the 20th century
art and the second
half 20th century,
there's been a seismic shift.
The work no longer
looks like European art.
I must say, in
the 1920s and even
'30s, a lot of the
art from the region
was influenced by Europeans.
But by the 1940s
and '50s and '60s,
you see the emergence
of an identity that
is very, very different,
that is very--
that is unique to that region.
This is the Baghdad Fine
Art Society of 1951.
However, fine art societies
emerged in Khartoum, in Kuwait,
in Cairo, in
Alexandria, in Rabat,
all over the Middle East,
in Beirut, and other places.
One of these intellectuals
was gathering--
I think he's somewhere
here, but I can't--
I don't know which
one he is here--
was Iraqi artist [AUDIO OUT].
So [INAUDIBLE] was
actually a person
who worked in the theater.
He designed a lot
of the background
for a lot of the plays.
But a lot of the plays
were political plays.
So when he gathers in
the fine art society,
the playwright gives the script.
The artist comes and
paints the background.
And so you have this
exchange of ideas.
So [INAUDIBLE] here makes this--
created this work, which
is [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]----
it has a French name
for some reason--
in 1957.
So what happened-- this is a
very interesting point that I
would like to share with you.
In Iraq, in the 1950s,
as part of the British--
as part of the British
government policies
or the British
influence in Iraq,
a lot of the land
that was taken--
that was controlled by
peasants in the South--
was taken over by the British.
They had airstrips.
They had a military base.
So they moved all these peasants
into Cairo, into Baghdad.
So you can imagine as a result
of several years of peasants
being pushed out of their
lands, they move where?
To the capital.
When they move to the
capital, what kind of jobs
are they going to get?
AUDIENCE: Laborer.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Laborer jobs.
Basically, they are
really in dire situation.
So in 1955, 1956, a couple
of seismic events took place.
Now, I want to explain how
artists channel what happened
politically into an artwork.
So in 1956, what
happened in Egypt?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Huh?
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: [INAUDIBLE],,
the Tripartite Aggression.
So what happened
was Abdel Nasser
had nationalized the Suez Canal.
And who attacked--
who attacked Egypt?
Israel, France, and Britain.
At the same time
in Baghdad, Baghdad
signs a treaty called
the Baghdad Pact
with the British government,
which is a joint defense pact.
At the same time that the
British were attacking
an Arab country, the
Baghdad government
signs a joint defense agreement.
The Iraqis go out and
march against this.
At the same time, they're
marching not only against
the Baghdad Pact--
that was the trigger--
but they are marching
against poverty.
They're marching against
lack of job opportunities
and employment and
livelihood opportunities.
And so these people are
called the [NON-ENGLISH]..
The [NON-ENGLISH] they came
from the [NON-ENGLISH]..
So they called them
the [NON-ENGLISH]..
So Kadhim Haidar, here,
painted the [NON-ENGLISH]..
He tells them, what happened?
What happened?
The [NON-ENGLISH] had gone
out and protest in 1957--
in '56 and '57.
So they were a
series of protests.
So he met him here.
He goes, tell me what happened.
So the painting was called,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
He has told us how it
happened, what happened.
So when you look at the
painting, you're like, ah,
Sultan is just talking shit.
It's a painting of a man
sitting down on the ground.
But really, these artists are
masters of hidden messages,
because they can
get into trouble.
What they do is they
hide their messages
in the corners, in the middle.
They find allegories.
They find metaphors for
what they want to say.
So when you look at this,
you see that bit over there?
You see that?
That's full of hidden
messages over here.
So here, the artist
is painting a man
who looks like
he's boxed in, who
looks like he's a strong man.
He must be what?
He must be in his 30s maybe.
You think he's in his
30s or maybe late 20s.
He's a strong man.
But he has no shoes on, and the
sole of his feet are cracked.
But he looks like he's
staring into the abyss.
Does he look like he
has a bright future
and a bright prospect?
Not much, is it?
Am I right?
So when you look at it, now you
can see the hidden messages.
What happened?
He tell him the soldiers
shot at the civilians.
What happened?
There were tanks and
planes that were--
there were tanks and planes
that were let loose on us,
and they dropped bombs.
And people were
crying, and people
were pleading for their
lives and running for cover.
What happened?
I saw rape.
Do you see?
Doesn't that give you goosebumps
about how the messages were
hidden by these artists?
Remember, the monarchy
was still there.
They were not able to
say what was happening.
So he had to hide
it in this painting.
I'll just go back just to give
you a chance to see it again.
I also love the
leftist red color here,
the communist color.
Almost the only color
that you see here
is the color-- the red
color of communism.
The same artist, Kadhim
Haidar, paints this work,
called "The Martyr's Epic."
So "The Martyr's Epic" basically
is a painting depicting
10 fatigued horses crying.
Why are they crying?
Because Kadhim Haidar
is saying, oh, I'm
painting a painting about the
martyrdom of Imam Husayn ibn
Ali.
So if you're not
Muslim, Imam Husayn
basically was the
grandson of the prophet.
And he was killed in
the Battle of Karbala.
And it was a major
seismic event that
really led to the split of
Islam between Shia and Sunni.
I don't want to go
into the details,
but he's a very important
figure for both Sunni and Shia
Muslims.
And so what happened is when
Abd al-Karim Qasim in 1957--
in 1957-58 overthrew
the king, he
stayed in power for five years.
And then, he was overthrown
by the Ba'athists.
So the Egyptian--
the Iraqi leader
only stayed in power
for five years.
And then, he was overthrown.
And so when he was
overthrown, they
went after his allies,
who were-- a lot of them
were the communists.
So remember, in the salon--
in the cultural salon,
a lot of people of
communist leanings
and communist backgrounds
were attending.
But guess what happened?
They went after them,
and they executed them.
They killed them.
They jailed them.
They locked them up in theaters.
They locked them
up in a stadium.
They locked them up in rooms.
And they executed many of them.
We'll come back to this theme.
The theme of execution
of communists
was a big deal in
the '60s in Iraq.
So again, Kadhim Haidar now--
in the 1960s,
remember how he hid
the message of the rape scene
and all that in the painting?
Here, he wanted to show
something else that happened,
which is what?
Which is the murder
of the intellectuals
of Iraq in the early '60s.
So he uses an allegory of
the death of Imam Husayn
to represent the death of
the intellectuals of Iraq.
Because he cannot paint an Iraqi
intellectual who was killed,
he says, I'm just
painting the deaths of--
the death of Imam Husayn--
Imam Husayn ibn Ali.
And that will be
the allegory, it
will be the metaphor for
my friends who were killed.
So here you see the horses
crying, because one of them
has been killed.
The sun has turned red.
You see the hair almost on
the back of their shoulders,
on their necks has
been-- has stood up.
They are in agony,
and they're crying.
And so again, a lot of
artists use these metaphors
to represent political events.
Ibrahim El-Salahi,
the same thing.
In 1985, painted
this piece in Sudan
called "The Inevitable,"
which was against the uprising
and the government of
Sudan had put down,
in a very nasty way, an
uprising that took place.
This is going back.
Mahmoud Sabri painted this
while he was in Russia.
In 1962, there was a--
the communist leader
of Iraq was executed.
So as you can see, he
was in Russia very much
painting in the Russian Soviet
realist style of painting.
I mean, look at this work.
Look at these individuals
carrying the red flag
of communism in the background.
Do you see them?
Look at the Salam Adil,
which was the nickname
of the Iraqi communist leader.
He was 29 years old
when he was executed.
But he's very proud.
Because this is what the
story is that he had his head
held up high.
Even though the
guy was in Russia,
he managed to
capture this scene.
And look at the guy who
was executed before him.
What do you see?
Do you see that he has fallen?
He's still trying to stand up.
So the guy who was
executed just before him
is pushing back up
because he refuses to die.
And look at the child
in the background
here who almost
is being inspired
by the sacrifice of
these individuals.
I'm sorry about the colors.
So it's a very, very important--
again, a very important piece.
The governments
in the Middle East
usually use artists to
create major monuments,
such as the Baghdad
Monument to Freedom,
that was created
by Jawad Saleem.
As you can see here, this
was Abd al-Karim Qasim,
who, remember, who
overthrew the king.
He went to Jawad Saleem and told
him, create a monument for me
to celebrate the new Iraq.
So as you can see here,
you have someone sort
of coming into the cage and
breaking the cage, which
is basically a metaphor
for the freedoms
that the Iraqis have won
by the overthrow of--
following the overthrow
of the monarchy.
This is still there
in Baghdad, thank God.
Now, a big theme in
the 1950s and '60s
was nationalism and Pan-Arabism,
which was championed
by Gamal Abdel Nasser.
You have this theme--
the nationalism
theme was all over the world.
This is the painting by
Ibrahim Ismail of Kuwait.
As you can see, he's showing
Abd [? al-Salam, ?] who was
the leader who
ushered in democracy--
who ushered in freedom and
independence of Kuwait.
You have the olive
branch, the bird of--
the dove of peace.
You have the
Constitution, et cetera,
all being shown here
in the flag of Kuwait.
But now is where it
gets really interesting.
This is the Kuwaiti painter
depicting Gamal Abdel Nasser.
Gamal Abdel Nasser
here is shown as what?
First of all, what flag--
who knows what flag this is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: What is that?
Someone explain it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
What is the name
of the country in English?
AUDIENCE: United Arab Republic.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
United Arab Republic,
which was the union of?
AUDIENCE: Egypt and Syria.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Egypt and Syria.
So this is a Kuwaiti
artist depicting
what Abdel Nasser meant to them,
someone from the Gulf saying,
Abdel Nasser now is the
leader of the region.
And the flag of the United Arab
Republic goes from the Maghreb,
from Morocco, all
the way to the Gulf.
So Abdel Nasser is the leader
of the whole region, basically.
Abdel Nasser was a larger
than life figure in--
almost literally
when it comes to art.
In this case, you have
Abdel Nasser here--
Hamid Ewais, who was another
leftist leaning artist,
socialist, who was very
friendly with Abdel Nasser
and depicts him here
and the nationalization
of the Suez Canal in 1957.
What do you see
in this painting?
You see Abdel Nasser surrounded
by people who are happy,
from diverse backgrounds.
And what do you see
in the background?
You see the first
vote sort of cross
under the era of Abdel Nasser.
So Abdel Nasser is
a recurrent theme.
I have 30, 40 paintings--
not have, but on the slides.
Here, I love.
This is one of my favorites.
This is Mohamed Sabri, who
is an Egyptian artist, who
is still alive-- born 1917.
Unbelievable, [NON-ENGLISH].
[KNOCK, KNOCK]
OK, so Mohamed
Sabri here depicts--
I want you to analyze
this piece for me.
What do you see?
What is Abdel Nasser doing here?
You guys analyze it.
AUDIENCE: It's the UN speech.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
It's the UN speech.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
OK, so who is he addressing?
Can you guys see?
AUDIENCE: The emerging nation.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Who is in the first row?
AUDIENCE: Russia and Chinese.
AUDIENCE: Russia
and [INAUDIBLE]..
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
OK, so the first row,
we see the leaders
of which countries?
America, Russia.
So the world powers are there.
And then who else is there?
AUDIENCE: India.
AUDIENCE: Ghana.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Why India and Ghana?
Why Ghana?
Why Indonesia?
Not India-- I think India is--
AUDIENCE: India.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Yeah, India-- it
says India and Indonesia.
But why Indonesia?
AUDIENCE: Muslims.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: No, there
was the conference, the
Indonesian Non-Aligned Movement
Conference in 1956,
which he attended.
What else do you see there?
There's an empty seat.
What's that empty seat?
AUDIENCE: His seat.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: His.
What is the message?
When he's done with the speech,
where is he going to go?
AUDIENCE: The front.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: He's going
to sit in the front, god dammit.
[LAUGHTER]
This guy is going to
sit in the front row.
He's not sitting in the back.
The Egyptian leader
sits in the front row
with the world leaders.
Do you think this
was the reality?
AUDIENCE: No.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
No, it wasn't the reality.
AUDIENCE: They still have
this complex today, though.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Yeah.
But it's not about--
but this is something.
It just shows you
the power of art.
Because these
paintings are meant
to be viewed by
the intellectuals
and by the influencers.
So you see Abdel Nasser.
And is Abdel Nasser
as big as them?
Is he his size?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: He's massive.
AUDIENCE: He's huge.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: He's massive.
And check out his teeth.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, wow, the
guy-- it's incredible.
The work-- I love
this painting so much.
And who's sitting
in the second row,
without us getting
into too much trouble?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Who said that country?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
I didn't say it.
[LAUGHTER]
But who else is there?
Everyone else is
relegated to the back.
AUDIENCE: But then you
have Castro as well.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Castro is his friend.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's true.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: That's Castro.
That's right.
Also, unfortunately,
they're all men.
But I suppose this is the
truth here in this-- in the UN.
So you can imagine how
Abdel Nasser's image
loomed over the region.
Not only do
Egyptians depict him,
but even Kuwaitis and
Syrians and Lebanese,
they all painted him as being
sort of this larger than life
figure.
You want to see another one?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: So here--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: The Last Supper.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Huh?
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
The Last Supper.
Actually, Tyler,
that's a good point.
Abdel Nasser died a few days
after signing this agreement,
unfortunately.
He was very young.
So this was the Cairo
Agreement in which he brought
all these leaders together.
What do you see
in this painting?
You see which leaders?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Palestine.
AUDIENCE: Turkey, Kuwait.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Yeah,
the leaders of Kuwait, Surdia,
Palestine.
Who is this?
AUDIENCE: British.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: No.
AUDIENCE: Muammar Gaddafi.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Muammar Gaddafi, well done.
Yeah, Muammar Gaddafi.
And I don't know who else is
there, to be honest with you.
AUDIENCE: Hussein is
next to him on the right?
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Who?
AUDIENCE: Hussein
is on the right?
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: On the right?
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Yeah.
This is King Husseing of--
is any one of them alive?
It's amazing that Gaddafi
was alive until recently.
OK, I think I have more.
Do you want to see more?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Let's see.
Oh, this was
actually a painting.
So this was interesting.
The Egyptian government,
[NON-ENGLISH]..
They were very, very
classy in the sense
that when they want to send the
message to the intelligentsia,
they bring in the
intelligentsia.
They chose over 20 artists,
and they shipped them down
to Aswan.
Abdel Nasser's project
was to build Aswan Dam.
Do you know how
important Aswan Dam was?
Aswan Dam was so important
that it was Egypt's--
their backup plan,
their plan of survival.
Because Egypt, in those
days, was able to muscle--
you know hand wrestle all the
countries of the Nile Basin.
Now, they can't do that.
Now, Ethiopia is
interfering with them.
But in those days,
they said, we're
building the MF
dam right now, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, we're building the dam.
And if the Americans don't give
us money, guess where we'll go?
We'll go to the Russians.
So this dam basically
was the reason
why Egypt shifted from
being in the Eastern--
sorry, from being in the
Western sphere of influence
to the Eastern
sphere of influence.
It's a major, major change.
So what they did was that
they chose 20 artists.
And they shipped
them to Aswan Dam
to paint what's
happening to Aswan Dam.
One of them was Ragheb
Ayad, who depicted--
I love this piece.
Because look at-- this is the
building of the Aswan Dam.
But if I didn't tell you it's
the Aswan Dam, what would
you think it was of?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: What
do you think they're building?
AUDIENCE: Pyramids.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: The pyramids.
Or maybe they're
digging the Suez Canal.
Am I right?
It's amazing.
I mean, for me, this
is an artwork that
celebrates the
Aswan Dam but almost
is critical of the Aswan Dam.
On one hand, they're
presenting Abdel Nasser--
or he was presenting
Abdel Nasser
as being the successor of the
[? hidewis ?] and the successor
of the pharaohs-- of the
pharaohs of thousands
of years ago.
But what's missing
in this painting?
There's something very
interesting that's
missing in this painting.
AUDIENCE: Muslim.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: No, if
you're building an effing dam,
you need what?
AUDIENCE: Water.
AUDIENCE: Terrain.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Not water,
but you need
equipment, machines.
Am I right?
Where is the machinery?
So it's almost
critical in the sense
that they're very primitive.
They're building, yes.
They're very primitive.
So in one hand, they're
showing you no idle hands,
but in the other
hand, they're showing
that people are literally
digging with shovels
the same way they did
thousands of years ago.
I love this piece so much.
This is a work that you
will not see anywhere
in the world except with me.
I went to Algeria.
I went to the Musee
des Beaux Arts.
I photographed it.
No one has an
image of this work.
It's such an incredible piece.
It's a piece by a Lebanese
artist called Arif El
Rayyes, who is a Pan-Arabist.
And he believed in the
Egyptian-- in the Algerian
revolution against the
uprising against the French.
And look what he did to them.
He sent this work [AUDIO OUT]
in 1961 to the Algerians.
But look at-- can you see
the message in this work?
Unfortunately, it's
not very clear.
But I can read to you.
What does it say here?
ORS.
What is ORS?
Any Algerians here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] The secret
army organization,
which is the--
sort of the gestapo
that was running
Algeria for the French--
sorry, on the behalf of
the French in Algeria.
So ORS is here.
And then you have here Europe,
then the Nazis, then Zionism.
So he's showing you that
all these are crocodiles
that are cutting the
legs of the Algerians
to make a stew out of them.
And then the United
Nations is going
to be eating from the Algerians.
So we can imagine how
bold and how creative
and how their feelings were sort
of regional rather than local.
So this is a piece
by Arif El Rayyes.
Here we go.
This is a piece by Hamid Ewais
called "The Guardian of Life."
So Hamid Ewais,
remember the guy who
did Abdel Nasser with the dam
and everyone smiling around him
and the ship is passing?
So Hamid Ewais was very
close to Abdel Nasser.
He was studying on a
scholarship in 1967-68 in Spain.
And he heard about
the defeat of Egypt.
Am I right to call
it the defeat,
the defeat of the Arab armies
at the hands of Israel?
And he wanted to
boost the morale.
Because remember, a quarter
of the area of the country
was taken over.
The Israelis had, at
one point in time,
almost approached the
borders of greater Cairo.
At one point in
time, the Israelis
had taken over
the Golan Heights.
They had taken
over the West Bank.
They had taken over Jerusalem.
They had taken over Gaza.
They had pushed
back the Jordanians.
back the Syrians.
They had taken
over all of Sinai.
And so a lot of artists,
including Hamid Ewais,
felt that they needed to
boost the morale of Egyptians.
Worry not, fret not.
The Egyptian man
will look after you.
You are safe and secure
under the protection
of the Egyptian man.
For some reason, a
lot of these paintings
had French names,
including this one.
But we changed the name here.
So can someone tell me what
you see in this painting?
AUDIENCE: Light.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
What's happening?
Someone explain this work.
AUDIENCE: There's a wedding.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: There's a what?
AUDIENCE: There's
a wedding, I guess.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: OK, before you
go to the details,
what's the overall image?
Before we go--
AUDIENCE: A protector.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: What?
AUDIENCE: Someone in
the army is protecting.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Someone is-- wait, is this?
AUDIENCE: Not the armies.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Do you think army?
AUDIENCE: No, it's someone.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
This is maybe more
of a peasant, maybe more of
a peasant, maybe more of--
I think the message
is the everyday man.
I don't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Huh?
Oh, sorry.
So what you see here, you
see sort of the everyday man.
The Egyptian was
carrying a weapon.
And the weapon is what?
It's a Russian.
It's a Russian weapon.
I think it's a
Kalashnikov or something.
I'm not sure.
What's in the background?
You see here the guys looking
to-- what is this area?
What is that?
It's not the dam, no.
It's not the dam.
It's Sinai.
This is Sinai that
was taken over.
But what is Sinai
represented as?
Is it very green, and there's
a lot of life and children
are playing?
What is Sinai to the Egyptians?
AUDIENCE: It's barren
land that we don't want.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
It's a barren land
that there's nothing really.
Why are you guys so upset?
You know, like, what's
the big deal, guys?
This was nothing.
It was just a little
bit of sand and desert.
And it disappeared.
And on the other hand that
he's protected behind him,
what's happening there?
What are the factories?
What's the smoke?
The smoke is industry, right?
What's happening?
Look, there's people
in the background.
There's a mosque.
There's homes.
Look at this.
What's this here?
Factory workers
coming back from work.
OK, so contrast both sides.
Look at the propaganda.
It's amazing.
Look at both sides.
And then, what's happening under
his hand, under his protection?
What do you see?
AUDIENCE: The community.
AUDIENCE: Life.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Huh?
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Life.
What do you see?
Give me more details.
AUDIENCE: Women and children.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Wedding, women and children.
We have an x-rated scene here.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, I don't know
where his hands are.
You have children playing.
Huh?
You have-- I'm not sure.
Is that a women breastfeeding?
Anyway, there's a lot of things
going on in this painting.
So basically, the
message, guys--
guys, the message
is life goes on.
Life goes on in Egypt under the
protection of the Egyptian man.
But not everyone was very
happy with Abdel Nasser.
Unlike Hamid Ewais, you
had Injia Efflatoun.
I told you about her before.
Remember her name.
She was an incredible woman.
I know I'm taking more
time than I should.
But Injia Efflatoun
was so important.
And I feel like someone needs
to make a movie about her life.
She was the daughter of a
middle class, upper middle class
family.
They spoke French at home.
They played the piano.
She had a tutor.
Her name was Inji.
Her sister was
Girespi or something.
You know, what is this family?
Some names like that.
So Inji Efflatoun
basically became
a member of this elitist
movement of Egypt.
She became a member of
this anti-revolution--
sorry, anti-monarchy,
pro-revolutionary movement.
And when the Egyptian
monarchy was overthrown,
she was excited, because
she was a communist.
And she saw that a new socialist
government is taking over.
However, by the
1950s, late '50s,
she realized that Abdel Nasser
was not communist enough.
He's like, what is this joke?
OK, I want someone who is
more radical than this.
We demand more.
So she became a member of
this Egyptian feminist group.
They went on a protest.
And in 1958, I think she
was arrested and thrown
in jail for four years
under Abdel Nasser.
She was not jailed
under the king.
She was jailed
under Abdel Nasser.
Can you imagine?
So when she was in jail,
she was able to smuggle--
there's a beautiful-- there's
an autobiography by her
that-- she had written
her own biography.
And she talks
about life in jail.
It's an incredible story.
But she was able to smuggle
in these small canvases
and paint the women
of the jail with her.
You know how we now
think we're very,
very smart when we use
the number seven to write
the [NON-ENGLISH],,
and I don't know what.
And the [NON-ENGLISH],, and
all these-- oh, we're so cool.
We're so millennial.
We can write this.
So Inji Efflatoun
did this in 1958.
If you guys think
you're so cool, so hip.
What she did, she wrote
letters to her sister.
I love this story.
She wrote letters to her sister
in Arabic using Latin script.
And then they thought she was
a spy, because she was writing
a lot of weird gibberish.
Literally, you read it--
it's Arabic but written in Latin
letters, in English letters.
And her lawyer-- because
only her and her sister
could read the letters.
And her lawyer argued
that his client is crazy.
And that's how she got
out of being in trouble.
But he said, how
can you even put her
in solitary confinement?
She's already crazy.
And she is writing--
what is this?
Nobody can read this.
So it's an amazing story.
So Inji Efflatoun went from
being a radical leftist
to being jailed and then
becoming sort of very yes-- no,
not anti-government as much.
I like this poster.
Again, it's a very
important poster of--
in 1982, it was the
first and only exhibition
of Arab art in Israel.
So as part of the
Camp David Accords,
the Egyptians agreed to
send art to Tel Aviv.
And so this was the
poster of the show.
Very little documentation
exists of this show.
But it was--
I want to show you as an example
of how the government also
use art for political ends.
Palestine is a major, major
theme in the Arab world.
And I will just skim
over it very quickly.
This is one of the most iconic
works by Ismail Shamout called,
"Where To?"
and was painted
five years after--
again, depicting
how a Palestinian,
basically, is going
from home to home.
And he's carrying his
children with him.
And he looks like
he's lost everything.
Here, you have [INAUDIBLE]
in 1960s depicting
the [NON-ENGLISH] who
are the freedom fighters.
[INAUDIBLE] again,
Marwan Kassab-Bachi
depicting Palestinian children
who are painted as giants.
So even though they're 15 years
old here, they're teenagers,
but they're painted as giants.
They look down on you.
This is based on a true story.
I don't want to go into it now.
Abdul Qader Al Rais
is from the UAE,
again, depicting
Palestinian throwing stones
at one of the occupation
soldiers in the background.
You can't see it, but there
is an occupation soldier
in the background.
Sliman Mansour, of course, the
most iconic painting, maybe,
of the Arab world of the 20th
century, Jamal Al Mahamel,
"Camel of Burdens."
Another work, al-Azzawi
"Sabra and Shatila"
painting, which was
acquired by the Tate Modern,
probably for over
a million dollars.
Nobody really knows
the number, but maybe
for over a million,
million and a half dollars.
I filmed an episode
of this work.
So you can watch it
if you want later.
Interestingly, the
Palestinians in 1978,
in the midst of the
Lebanese civil war, which
is really interesting for
me, invited 200 artists
from around the world to
send works in solidarity
with the Palestinians.
And the work made
it through Lebanon,
and it was shown in Lebanon.
And all these artists
from all over the world--
Latin America, Europe,
the Middle East--
all sent paintings to Palestine.
It was called the International
Exhibition for Solidarity
or something with Palestine.
This is a picture from it.
The exhibition only lasted
for about a month or so.
This is a list of
artists that took place.
You can see it.
But unfortunately,
a lot of the works
were destroyed or
disappeared, because they
were kept in storage in the
PLO headquarters in Beirut.
And guess what the
first thing the Israelis
did in 1982 when
they stormed Beirut?
They went after the
PLO headquarters,
and they demolished and
they stole a lot of things.
This is a fascinating piece
by a Palestinian artist,
very political work.
If you look at this
work, and you say,
ah, it's just a cactus.
Sultan is bullshitting again.
[LAUGHTER]
But actually, it's
a very, very--
it's all about
identity politics.
Asim Abu Shaqra
was a Palestinian
born in the town of Umm al-Fahm
in northern occupied Palestine
and northern Israel.
And he was one of the
very first Palestinians
to enter into the Kalisher
Academy of Art, which is later
incorporated into Tel Aviv art--
Tel Aviv University.
And he started painting
the sabra, the cactus,
as a symbol of
Palestinian resistance.
And a lot of people
didn't understand what
he was doing in those years.
Unfortunately, he
died at the age of 28
from asbestos
poisoning and cancer.
But he was-- just like van Gogh,
who was doing the sunflowers,
he kept painting over
and over the cactus.
But what is the symbolism of
cactus for the Palestinians?
AUDIENCE: Resilience.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Well done.
I don't know who said that.
Thank you.
Resilience.
So the fact that a
cactus plant or a cacti
can resist the fact that
they're from the ground.
The fact that they don't
change their thorns no matter
how long time passes.
They stay.
The fact that they can survive
in different conditions
under pressure.
So he sort of compared
himself to the cactus
that has been removed from the
wilderness and from Umm al-Fahm
and planted in Tel Aviv
and put into a pot.
So he sort of uses identity
politics in his art.
There's so much to say
about Asim Abu Shaqra,
but I will skip so that we can
all go home and have dinner.
Again, Khaled Jarrar,
another Palestinian artist
who went through
the apartheid wall
and started chipping
pieces from it
and reconstituting it
into toys, a bear, bread--
in this case, a
volleyball, doing
more than one thing, number one,
representing all the children
who have been stopped from
playing with each other because
of the giant wall that
came up in between them.
So all the football
fields, all the volleyball
whatever you want to call
them, the playing fields that
have been disrupted.
But also, he's mocking the wall.
He's saying, this wall
is nothing for us.
He is making a mockery
of the war itself.
This is a short video
I will show you.
So in 2011 or so, a Palestinian
artist based in Denmark,
called Larissa Sansour, applied
for a competition in Geneva.
The competition was
sponsored by Lacoste.
And it was organized by a
museum called the Musee de
l'Elysee in Geneve.
And when she submitted
the idea, she's
like, this is what I want to do.
Lacoste was like, WTF?
No, thanks.
They're like, we
don't like this idea.
It's too political.
What do you want to do?
Oh, I have this idea to
create a tower in Palestine
where all the
Palestinians can live.
And this will be a solution
to the Palestinian problem.
We will build a skyscraper.
And all the Palestinians
will live in Palestine
within the skyscraper.
Of course, she has
artistic license.
She is not serious, but
this is her art project.
And Lacoste were horrified.
They said they saw it
and were like, no, no no.
Change it.
And she goes, I'm
not changing my art.
And they said, change it.
I'm not changing it.
You're not changing it?
Then you're disqualified.
You're out of the competition.
And so a lot of
people came together
and raised money for
her to create the video
that I'm going to show you.
It's a long video, so I'm only
showing you a short clip of it.
But as you see, this is
Larissa herself waiting
in the lobby of the skyscraper.
You see every city in every
town of Palestine is one floor.
So basically, the idea that
everyone from Jerusalem
lives in the second floor.
Everyone from Nazareth
lives in the sixth floor.
So here she's seen watering
her, of course, an olive tree.
And you see that
she's overlooking
the Al-Aqsa in the background.
And I think now I'm
going to show you just--
maybe just a minute
of the video.
This is the introduction
on how she's arrived--
she's arriving now
at the skyscraper.
She's moving in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
She's also a fashion designer,
so everything you see here,
she's designed herself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Have they shown the
Palestine flags, or not yet?
AUDIENCE: Not yet.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
These are all of the towns.
The name of the video is "Nation
State," not "Nation States."
Oh, this is the poster,
"Living the High Life."
So smart.
OK, so let's move on.
It's a 7 and 1/2 minute video.
Oh, that's her sister,
by the way, and her--
and her brother, I
think, in the video.
Again, all the clothes
are designed by her,
because she's into
science fiction.
And I think if I press
a button I can move on.
Maybe you have to exit.
Wonderful.
Oh yeah, so pre-Arab Spring--
so a lot of artists depicted
a lot of political events,
including the destruction
of Iraq in the 1991 war.
Here, you see one of the
sculpture of Ishtar crying.
The red flag, the angel,
has had its limbs cut off.
This is poster by a Kuwaiti
that became a stencil
during the occupation of Saddam
forces of Kuwait in 1991.
I love these two works.
This is an artist
called Walid Ebeid
who depicted a lot of the
events in Egypt that really
led to the uprising of 2011.
In this case, he shows
you the bread line.
So one of the slogans of the
Egyptian uprising of 2011 was
[NON-ENGLISH], which is bread.
So people wanted bread.
So here, he's showing
you the bread lines
as far back as 2005, and
this is not the first time
that riots erupted in
Egypt because of bread.
So you see here, a lot of
these people standing in line.
They have cash in
hand, but there isn't
enough bread for everybody.
Even though they have
the money, there's just
five or six loaves of bread.
And there there's so many
more people waiting outside.
Again, Walid Ebeid
here depicting
a lot of the injustices
that were taking place,
a lot of the police
brutality against some
of the Egyptians in the 2007--
again 2007, 2008, 2009, 2010
led to a lot of anger
in the streets of Egypt.
I love this work by Mohssin
Haraki, a Moroccan artist
who talks about the
fossilization of education
in Morocco.
So as you see here, he has--
not only does he have
the history book,
he has the religious
studies book
also as part of the series.
But I love that he
has the Constitution.
So he says that the Constitution
is not being updated.
It's fossilized.
It's become cemented.
So again, artists are talking
about political issues
through their art in the region.
This is a work that we got into
some hot water in Singapore
when we showed it.
It's a piece by Sharif Waked,
the Palestinian artist.
Basically, when you see this,
what's the first word you see?
What's the first
word you think of?
Quick.
AUDIENCE: ISIS.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: ISIS, wow.
OK, another word?
AUDIENCE: Terrorist.
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Terrorist, yes.
OK, so I'm not sure ISIS
has done this before,
but you're right.
AUDIENCE: Top of mind.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
Top of your mind.
So basically, I want to
explain this work for you,
because it's very important.
Sharif Waked talks about
how you judge people
from the first hand--
from the first sight.
Here, he talks about
this individual
that you immediately assume
is someone who wants to die.
However, when you
play the video, which
I will not be playing
for you to save time,
he is reading a book.
What's the book
that he's reading?
He's reading a book,
"1,001 Arabian Nights."
And I'm sure you know the story
of "1,001 Arabian Nights."
Someone tell me the story quick.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: Scheherazade
tells what to Shahryar?
What does she want from him?
AUDIENCE: To keep her alive.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
To keep her alive.
Does she want to die?
AUDIENCE: No.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
She doesn't want to die.
She wants to live another day.
Likewise, this individual
doesn't want to die.
He wants to live another day.
So that's the idea of the work.
A lot of artists, like
Ali Cherri of Lebanon,
depicted contemporary events
with this 2011 uprising.
Or Sulafa Hijazi, which I
love this work very much, very
controversial.
Does anybody here want to
imagine what it's about?
So you all know the story of
Rapunzel, the German fable.
So the idea here is
that some of the clerics
are giving a helping hand
for some of the militants
to rise up.
So Sulafa Hijazi is a
Syrian based in Berlin,
a very controversial piece.
I have another controversial
piece coming up.
So if you feel offended,
you should look away now.
So this is a work, again,
by Sulafa Hijazi from 2011.
She's talking, basically,
about these soldiers who
feel that they have some
kind of raw emotion,
that they get sexually
aroused in a way when
it comes to seeing
protesters in the street.
They see them
protesting, and they
get that they want
to shoot their load.
They want to go after them.
You know what I mean?
They're almost like an
animalistic feeling.
This work, I really like.
Abdulnasser Gharem was
a lieutenant colonel,
I think, in the Saudi Air Force.
And in 2009, he created
this work called,
"No More Tears," where he
took the stickers of-- you
know Johnson & Johnson?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
I'm sure your moms all--
you showered as kids
in Johnson & Johnson.
And so he removed the
Johnson & Johnson stickers,
and he placed them on a
map of the Arab world.
So in 2009, you can imagine,
what were the trouble spots?
Someone tell me, what
were the trouble spots
of the Arab world?
AUDIENCE: Iraq.
AUDIENCE: Syria.
AUDIENCE: Palestine.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Iraq.
Iraq, Palestine, Somalia.
No, in 2009.
AUDIENCE: South Sudan.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
South Sudan, 2009.
The interesting thing
also-- before we
move to the next work,
the interesting thing
about this work is, what
do the no more tears drops
look like as well.
AUDIENCE: Blood.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Blood?
Good.
And?
AUDIENCE: Bombs, I guess.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
No, something else.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: No.
What do we export in the Gulf?
AUDIENCE: Oil.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Oil.
They look like oil, drops of
oil, when you look at them.
Anyway, so what he did
was that he revisits--
in 2014, he revisits
the theme of this work.
And he creates an
updated version.
Can you imagine what happened?
Do you want to see?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI:
This is what happened.
It's all over the region.
There's really the agony and
sadness all over the region--
in Libya, in Syria,
in Tunis, in Yemen.
AUDIENCE: In spite
of the three drops
that weren't on the map
in the previous one,
was he hinting that they
were going somewhere?
SULTAN SOOUD AL QASSEMI: Maybe
he's predicting the future.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SULTAN SOOUD AL
QASSEMI: More to come--
another bigger-- they're
bigger and bigger.
Yeah, it's a disaster.
So this is interesting.
We have one work
left to show you.
So a lot of people
in the Gulf, they're
very careful when they're
critical of the governments.
And so you don't
see a lot of artwork
that are critical
of governments here.
But this is an interesting
piece by a GCC artist
called the GCC,
the micro-council.
The collective is called
the GCC Collective.
And this work from 2014 is it--
2013, they create--
they recreate
the GCC, the table where
they meet, all the leaders.
And you look at
the work, and you
think, oh, it's very beautiful.
All the flags are there.
The rubbish bins are made
of gold or whatever that is.
They're all meeting.
However, most Kuwaitis
have much more leeway
and freedom when it comes
to political discussion.
They wanted to put
them in context.
So you can imagine.
So what the message basically
is that you will be scrutinized.
So when you visit this work
and you walk next to it,
you look down and you
scrutinize the meeting--
the meeting and the
leaders themselves.
So this is the whole
idea of the work.
So this is how Kuwaitis sort
of interact with events here
in the region.
Very last work that
I will show you,
unfortunately, is the work I
feel that reflects the region.
I'm always sad to
end with this piece.
It's a piece by
Mona Hatoum, who was
a Beirut-born, Palestinian
artist now based
in the UK-- is very, very
important, had solo exhibitions
all over the world.
Mona Hatoum's
"Infinity" basically
encompasses the region.
What you see is soldiers
standing in eternal fights,
shooting each other forever.
They are depicted as
toys, because they
are being controlled by others.
They are replaceable.
Have you ever seen
the green soldiers?
When you lose one of them,
you just buy another batch.
So the idea is that they
really keep replenishing.
They're never-ending.
And they're also placed
on a coffee table.
And the idea of placing
them on a coffee table
is to show you how
wars are domesticated.
Wars have effects
on the household.
And I feel like
this really reflects
the region where you have
eternal, perpetual wars, wars
that affect the region,
where people are almost
standing constantly with a gun
to the back of someone else,
and you never know
what's coming for you,
and also the idea that there
is always an endless supply
of available people to fight.
But this is the end
of the presentation.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]